і про те як вчаться зараз школярі та
студенти в умовах коли зникає інтернет
та зв'язок ми поговоримо просто зараз з
міністром освіти та науки України
Сергієм шкарликом він вже на прямому
зв'язку з нашою студією п Сергію Вітаємо
вас
Вітаю вас Дякую за під е-е за увагу до
питання освіти і слава Україні
героям слава пана Сергію перш за все
Давайте поговоримо про заняття В
нинішніх суворих таких умовах Як впливає
на навчальний процес відключення світла
наприклад а також відключення інтернету
під час уроків як у школі Так і вдома що
в цих умовах можна зробити щоб не
постраждала головніше якістю освіти
я вам дякую за запитання надзвичайно
актуальне в наших сьогоднішніх умовах
відключення світла економія
електроенергії енергоресурсів Це
сьогодні необхідна міра для збереження
енергетичної стабільності по всій
території України
при спілкуванні своїми колегами головами
військових адміністрацій ми завжди
намагаємось щоб під час уроків світло не
вимикалось містах розташування шкіл
однак при цьому є й окремі випадки але
при цьому найголовніше це бажання
навчатися і завжди можна надолужити
пропущену тему саме цим намагаються е-е
і оперувати наше освітяни
Окрім цього ми запровадили цілу низку
електронних додатків які дозволяють все
ж таки навіть в умовах відключення
світла
в режимі відсутності інтернету працювати
з електронними ресурсами наприклад
електронна бібліотека яка на порталі
інституту модернізації змісту освіти цей
1 300 35 підручників і посібників всіх
назв з першого по 11-й клас наприклад
наше видавництво Ранок учнів і педагогам
надали Відкритий доступ до електронних
підручників для першого п'ятого класу з
усіх предметів компанія at Pro відкрила
до 31 грудня безоплатних доступ до
електронних підручників на нашій
платформі всеукраїнської школи онлайн
сьогодні розташовано дві з половиною
тисячі навчальних курсів і плюс до кінця
року буде завантажено ще 1 000 ми
запровадили
єдиний деміфікований застосунок вивчаю
Не чекаю які дозволяє навіть в умовах
відсутності інтернету учням
перших-четвертих класів опановувати
освітній контент робимо все можливе аби
рівень знань українських учнів був не
знижувався і був на будь-якому рівні
зрозуміло пана Сергію в цьому питанні ми
готові А ось інший момент як розпочався
опалювальний сезон цьогоріч в закладах
освіти зокрема в школах та університетах
чи є такі регіони де в класах та
аудиторіях досі холодно і як зарадити
такій ситуації
ви знаєте 100%
готовність досягти ми в будь-якому
випадку не зможемо оскільки в окремих
областях це не дозволяє безпекова
ситуація однак на сьогодні є ціле низько
областей де не відбувається постійних
обстрілів і готовність усіх закладів
освіти до опалювального сезону на
надзвичайно належному рівні якщо взяти в
цілому по країні наприклад заклади
фахової перевищують та вищої освіти
тобто коледжі університети загальна
готовність в нас на цьогоріч 70 на цей
на цю дату 78 відсотків заклади про в
техосвіти загальна готовність
88%. заклади загальної середньої освіти
тобто школи це 92% готовності по країні
до шкільна освіта готова теж на 92%.»
цього диска Полтавська Рівненська
Тернопільська Хмельницької Чернівецька
сьогодні мав честь особисто
в цьому переконатись на прикладі
Тернопільської області в якому дійсно на
100% всі заклади освіти готові до
опалювального сезону якщо брати школи то
на 100%
дітей і місто Київ садочки на 100%
готові в 13-ти областях і в місті Києві
зрозуміло пан Сергію А ось яке питання
Скільки очно чи змішано навчається зараз
дітей по країні Чи маєте ви Таку
статистику як масовані обстріли ворога
впливають на освітній процес взагалі
Я вам дуже дякую за запитання адже якщо
брати загальну кількість закладів
загальної середньої освіти А це 12916
традиційному повноформатному режимі
навчається 383 школи змішано навчається
3500 три школи і 6 330 навчається в
онлайн режимі тобто Приблизно 50 на 50
.»
Я вам дуже дякую за запитання Дуже дякую
вам за запитання адже
встановлення канікул є при рогатива
засновника
керівництвом закладу освіти з педрадою
на сьогодні наприклад тільки на прикладі
Тернопільської області хочу сказати
Сумно стратегію формування канікулярного
періоду для школярів адже на сьогодні
суттєво
покращується погодні умови по
значно потеплішає і тому в майже 100%
школи сьогодні продовжують освітній
процес до того часу коли почнеться
опалювальний сезон а а щодо зимових
канікул ми будемо бачити яким чином буде
проходити температурний режим взимку І в
залежності від того наскільки Ми
сьогодні зможемо опанувати потужність і
опанувати програму освітнього процесу ми
будемо бачити яким чином ми будемо
формувати на сьогодні
стратегію щодо зимових канікул в цілому
в Україні в принципі канікули мали
початися цього тижня в деяких регіонах
але не переважній більшості будуть
починатися канікули з 31
жовтня бо за 7 листопада
Зрозуміло дякую пане Сергію що знайшли
час поспілкуватись з нами сьогодні на
прямому зв'язку був міністр освіти та
науки України Сергій шкарлет